so listen there is an investigation into
joe biden's son hunter biden that is
reportedly going on
and i i really want to speak to
you to the progressives in the audience
in the sense that for months really
almost for years now the right and
republicans and the trumpian right has
been talking about hunter biden's laptop
hunter biden's laptop hunter biden's
criminality joe biden's criminality
linked to hunter biden and we have taken
each story one at a time and each claim
one at a time and said here's the lies
here's the lies here's the lies i've
also said before
that if hunter biden maybe did something
wrong
he should be investigated and unlike
donald trump joe biden shouldn't try to
interfere with that investigation joe
biden shouldn't try to
affect or influence that investigation
in any way
and if hunter biden has committed a
crime he should be charged
and if he is convicted he should be
punished this is a very different
perspective than that of the trumpian
right which is obfuscate
obstruct
influence and try to affect legal
proceedings so we should be consistent
and that's exactly what i'm going to be
first of all i'm not going to hide from
you that it now appears there is a
federal investigation into hunter biden
big report yesterday from cnn
federal investigation of hunter biden
heats up now it has nothing to do with
the laptop may be disappointing to some
republicans in our audience cnn reports
a justice department investigation into
hunter biden's business activities has
gained steam in recent months with a
flurry of witnesses providing testimony
to federal investigators and more
expected to provide interviews in the
coming weeks according to multiple
sources familiar with the matter okay
what are the origins or oranges of this
investigation well
the probe led by the u.s attorney in
wilmington delaware began as early as
2018
and it concerns multiple financial and
business activities in foreign countries
dating to when joe biden was vice
president
investigators have examined whether
hunter biden and some of his associates
associates violated money laundering tax
and foreign lobbying laws as well as
firearm and other regulations these are
that's a serious investigation
um hunter biden has not been charged
with any crimes has denied wrongdoing
his father president joe biden is not
being investigated as part of the probe
of his son's business activities
according to sources who have been
briefed
but the ongoing investigation has
persistently raised questions about the
ethics and behavior of the president's
son and has fueled right-wing political
attacks in 2019 then president trump
pressured ukraine to investigate the
bidens over hunter's work for burisma
a ukrainian energy company eventually
leading to trump's first impeachment
so
guys
let's just allow this to happen right i
mean investigate
do whatever you need to do
i don't care about hunter biden as in in
terms of you know as a political program
in terms of political analysis unlike
jared kushner
unlike ivanka trump
unlike so many of trump's cronies
hunter has nothing to do with joe
biden's administration hunter has
nothing to do with policy hunter's not
sitting in for the secretary of state
the way ivanka was at the g20 or
whatever meeting it was i have no
interest in defending hunter biden
there's nothing linking joe biden to any
of this hunter biden is being
investigated for things he did as a
private citizen if he did something
wrong then charge the guy if you want to
throw the book at him throw the book at
him if he's found guilty of any crimes
we shouldn't apply a different standard
now at the same time it's worth
remembering
that what's going on with hunter biden
reinforces
that what appears to be the trump crime
family should be investigated
and uh we continue to wonder
what's going on what's going on
manhattan investigators quitting because
they got the impression that even though
they found evidence of trump felonies
not trump's kids trump felonies that no
charges were forthcoming i told you on
monday or tuesday that a federal judge
has indicated evidence should be
provided
on the basis that it seems likely that
trump committed felonies merit garland
seems to have absolutely no interest in
pursuing any of it so investigate hunter
investigate trump there's evidence of
felonies charge all of them here's a
quick report from cbs news about this
multiple sources tell cbs news that the
federal investigation into hunter
biden's business practices is broader
than previously known
the probe is exploring whether the
younger biden and his associates
violated tax money laundering and
foreign lobbying laws business records
reviewed by cbs news and documents
released by republicans in congress
indicate multiple financial transactions
involving hunter biden his firm and a
chinese energy company called cefc
republicans allege that the company is
an arm of the chinese government
investigate all of it so let's be
consistent guys let's be consistent
everybody who has uh who is suspected of
wrongdoing should be investigated if
he's cleared he will be cleared if he's
not he can be charged that's it and we
need to remember
when we talk about the laptop claims and
uh rudy giuliani's uh evidence that he
has in his den or whatever when it's
wacky and cartoonish we debunk it
separately there's an investigation
going on and it should and nobody should
interfere in it if you disagree with my
perspective let me know you can find me
on twitter deepakman and i'm glad to
follow up on it
one of our sponsors is blinkist who's
been supporting the david pakman show
longer than any other sponsor blinkist
is the app that lets you listen to or
read an entire non-fiction book in just
15 minutes blinkist is the way to absorb
those books you can't make time for
blinkist takes top non-fiction titles
pulls out the book's key takeaways and
insights and gives it to you in the form
of a text or audio explainer that you
can consume in 15 minutes with blinkist
now you actually do have time to learn
about all the things you've been wanting
to tackle on the blinkist app i just
listened to this is your mind on plants
by the great michael pollan
super interesting the history of
caffeine and so many other things
blinkist has you covered on podcast too
2 blinkist takes long episodes of
popular podcasts and distills them into
audio you can listen to in 15 minutes
with blinkist you can become
knowledgeable about so many different
things you can have conversations with
people about more topics blinkist makes
you more well-rounded
try blinkist for free and get 25 off a
subscription go to blinkist.com
pacman the link is down below